[Drummer] "But a Belter opened it.
We are the Belt!
We are sharp and we don't feel fear.
Hey guys, Pete here.
I've got a new expanse video for you today.
But real quick,
This video is brought to you by Squarespace
use their all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online presence
and run your business at
Squarespace.
So, today, I'm going to
Talk about one of my favorite characters in
The Expanse
TV show Camina Drummer.
I say the show because while there is a character
named Drummer in the books,
what we've seen so far has been a combination
of several characters
that were cut when they adapted
the story for the screen.
This has made her a bit of a wild card for
people who've read the
novels and Cara Gee's amazing performance
has elevated
the character to being a whole that is truly
greater than the sum of her parts.
I'm going to talk about the character's journey
and why I think
she has turned out to be the most interesting
example of what it means
to be a Belter.
As far as spoilers,
I'll be talking about things that happen through
the fifth season of the TV series.
If you're not caught up to the end of that,
then this video might not be for you.
And with that out of the way, let's get into
it.
I think the clip I opened the video with is
the most memorable Drummer
moment, but it was probably when she executed
the two Black Sky,
Belters on Tycho that I realized what an absolute
scene-stealer
this character is.
She rose to be the captain of the Behemoth
and later Medina
station, but over the seasons Drummer has
taken on a number of roles.
When we first met her in season 2 she was
working under Fred Johnson as his second-in-command
at Tycho station.
Right off the bat,
in her first couple of scenes, we learned
that she's competent,
she has a presence, and that Fred Johnson
trusts her to the point of
making her his Security Chief.
She's involved in the raid on Thoth station,
and then she oversees the
repairs on the Rocinante afterward.
She also starts to form a friendship with
Naomi,
who is the only Belter on the Roci and in
one of their early scenes
together we learn that she likes to hydrate
with beers.
We also pick up details about her background
throughout season 2.
She was born and raised on Ceres.
She worked the docks where she eventually
came into contact with
Anderson Dawes.
Over time
It sounds like she worked her way up to become
a high-ranking member
of his faction in the OPA and she was there
when Dawes found Fred
Johnson who in a low point after Anderson
station, basically came to
the Belt to commit suicide by Belter.
She played a role in convincing Dawes to save
Fred rather than killing
him, which is what led to him staying in the
Belt, and creating his
own OPA faction as an earther.
At some point, Drummer broke with Dawes and
decided to follow Fred to
Tycho station where we meet her.
She plays a role in launching the Nauvoo in
an attempt to push Eros
into the Sun and helps take control
of the nuclear missiles that were launched
at it by Earth.
Those along
with her, loyalty to Fred earn her, a bullet
in her belly, but she
does even the score there before it's all
said and done.
the attempt to
take control of the missiles, was instigated
by Dawes, who had
approached her earlier where he came on strong,
hinting that there is
more than just a working relationship in their
past.
And it became clear that he was trying to
get close to her, trying to
learn about the secret weapon that Fred had
alluded to
All of this caused tension when Fred got ahold
of the Protomolecule
sample through Naomi. he made the decision
to tell Dawes
about it because he wanted access to Cortazar,
which Drummer couldn't
believe because he had kidnapped the Protogen
scientist right out
from under him.
This causes Drummer to reconsider things in
relation to Fred,
but later she still takes a belter fleet to
recover the Nauvoo and
start the process of retrofitting it into
the
OPAs first warship.
So the seeds are planted for a
very complicated story at this point.
Drummer is now the captain of the Behemoth.
She's reunited with Naomi who has come on
board to be the chief engineer,
and they take on Ashford, who is associated
with the Anderson Dawes
faction.
For all appearances
He doesn't show her the respect that she thinks
that she deserves as
the captain, and he does several things that
seem to undermine her Authority.
Things take a turn when Clarissa Mao launches
her plan to try to
destroy Holden.
She destroys the Seung-Un and transmits the
video of Holden taking
responsibility in the name of the OPA and
declaring that only the
belt has legitimate claim to the ring. even
though Naomi tries to
assure them that Holden would never do that
they're in a position where they have to do
something before the UN
retaliates.
not just against the rocinante but also their
ship the Behemoth.
So drummer has to make the tough decision
to take a shot at them to make it clear that
they're not working
together.
that forces the Roci to become the first ship
to transit
the ring successfully after Holden talks to
Proto Miller.
They do survive but unsurprisingly Naomi is
upset and that leads to
her coming to the conclusion that she belongs
on the Roci.
Which over time we came to realize as a big
loss for drummer who had
developed deep feelings for her.
And in respect for that
she just has to let her go. when the Martians
decide to go into the
Slow Zone after the Roci
they warned the other ships not to follow,
but Ashford and
Drummer realized that this will create a situation
where the belters
are shut out completely.
So they decide to Transit the ring with the
Behemoth.
And this is where she delivers that incredible
speech with Ashford
starting the beat and everyone chanting by
the end. and they do
Transit, which earns the belt a seat at the
table.
There's some tension over drummer, letting
Naomi go, which in a
roundabout way leads to Drummer and Ashford
finding themselves pinned
against some farming equipment after the speed
limit changed again.
This is another amazing scene where we get
to see them talk about
their pasts and then eventually realizing
that there's nothing else
that they can do Drummer allows herself to
be crushed
So that Ashford could get free.
that crushes he spine and leaves
her without feeling in her legs.
This doesn't stop her though
because when Ashford takes over and gets the
dangerous idea of
shooting the ring with the Behemoth's communication
laser, she
puts a Mech together that allows her to walk
again.
She helps Naomi and Holden get back together
and in their effort to try
to reach the bridge.
when they're pursued by Diogo,
who now has some power armor,
she plans to sacrifice herself to take him
out, but is saved at the
last second and doesn't have to go through
with it.
The crisis in the slow Zone comes to an end
and when you next see Drummer she's healing
and has become the
captain of what is now called Medina station.
And we'll get to the next chapter in her life.
After a quick mention that,
They sponsor Squarespace in an earlier chapter
in my life.
I used to work for a firm that built websites
and I found Squarespace
to be really user-friendly.
It was simple to jump right in and start to
create a website or you
could put together an online store with marketing
tools and analytics
built in for what I was looking to do.
The video blocks were great.
Just paste the URL and upload a custom thumbnail.
And I appreciated that all the templates have
built in mobile websites.
Just make it once and it looks great.
Great across all devices while you're working.
You can toggle the views back and forth and
get the design, just how you like it.
Check out squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch, go to squarespace.com,
Pete Peppers,
to save 10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain.
So now drummer is the captain of Medina, which
is parked inside the
Slow Zone. because she got the ship through
the ring
they were able to leave it there.
They changed the name and are now in a great
position to coordinate things
Once the blockade is lifted by the UN.
Colony ships will be able to
pass through the ring Gates and access
The worlds Beyond and Fred Johnson's faction
of the OPA will be at the
center of it.
And even though her role is toned down in
the fourth season.
I think this is where things get really interesting.
I mean her scenes from the end of season 2
through season 3 had pretty
much been a highlight reel, but here she has
to try to work with the
inners in the new peace treaty that Fred and
Dawes negotiated and
in a conversation with Naomi
she also lays out her feelings about belters
going through the Rings
and transitioning to living on planets.
She believes that belters belong in space,
within two generations on a planet
They'll be inners and will have forgotten
their culture and Roots
Naomi counters this
with everyone has the right to decide for
themselves.
And while she agrees, you can see how much
the idea bothers Camina.
she reconciles what's Ashford and they investigate
an incident where
everyone on board a Colony ship are spaced.
There are factions of the OPA that are against
the peace treaty with
the inners and they're carrying out attacks
to send a message.
Marco
Inaros is brought to them for a reward and
they try to get answers out of him.
They learned that he has something going on
with somebody on Mars, but
he shuts things down when he figures out what
they're doing.
They give him a trial with the leaders of
three other factions there
to judge, and it comes down where they're
split, and Drummer has to
use her deciding vote to let Marco live.
She explains that she did actually want him
dead
but understood that a civil war could break
out if she went against the
Black Sky, and golden bough.
This turns out to cause her real problems
and eventually brings about
the end of her time working for Fred Johnson.
Marco make some moves
that provoked the UN,
they take a more active role in the Slow Zone
and then Fred works out
a deal that she doesn't approve of.
She makes some good points that Fred can't
really counter, but he's
able to pull the card about her letting inaros
live.
And in the end she quits.
before she leaves,
Ashford comes to try to talk her out of it
and they talk about the
inner planets history of imperialism and violence
while looking at the Mormon paintings.
She says she believed in Fred's vision of
a free and independent belt,
but now that they have reached that point
They're painting the same picture.
They're playing with the lives of Innocents
in exchange for peace.
She expected Ashford to take over her job
but learns that he's going
out to try to kill Marco
and he offers her the job of XO on the Tynan
for the mission if she wants it.
She decides against it and tells him that
she's getting away from all of it.
She gives him a bottle of liquor as a present
which he gives back
saying that they can share it together when
he returns.
And then they say goodbye.
And it's the last time that they'll see each
other because Ashford is
killed by Marco in the season four finale.
The fifth season starts out with drummer in
a much different place.
She managed to leave your old life behind
and became the
captain of a small group of ships that get
by through scavenging.
The crew is more than that
There are polyamorous family, which had been
led by Oksana before they
brought Drummer in.
It's a tight-knit group with that added emotional
connection, and she
seems to care deeply for her partners.
He see that they're getting by trying not
to resort to violence, but
we'll protect the territory they've carved
out.
When they come across a pirate that attacked
a colony ship.
That doesn't want to cut them in.
They attack and disable the ship.
They Eventually locate Ashford ship the Tynan
and discover is backup data core.
When she goes through it
he hears the recording he made of Marco.
As his life was ending, this puts her on the
path of Revenge and she
tells her family that she wants to kill Marco
so they can collect the Bounty.
They can see through this though and know
that it's personal and that
it's extremely dangerous and they are able
to talk her out of it after
Marcos attacks on Earth and Tycho station
neutrality isn't an option
her family is forced to make a decision.
Join the free Navy or risk being hunted down,
which isn't really a
choice after all and to make things more complicated.
They have to do a crew exchange which puts
one of Drummer's family
members on the Pella and brings Karal who
is pretty much hostile
onto the Tynan.
This is where Drummer really becomes the embodiment
of the Belter struggle.
There is no where she can go to get away from
this.
On the one side.
She has a man who is an extremist,
who has committed atrocities against humanity
and is responsible
for killing people.
She was close to on the other side.
You have the imperialist powers that have
subjugated her people and
culture the literal boot on their neck.
It would go against the fabric of her identity
to side with the inners.
And if she were to go that way, she might
just get herself in her.
Family killed in the process.
When said atrocities guy makes it explicitly
personal and orders her
to kill her good friend's
crew and destroyed their ship
She reaches a Breaking Point.
She turns against the free Navy.
She turns the battle in the Rocinante's favor
and she knows she's risking everything
while she does it.
In retaliation
her husband is killed on the Pella, half of
her family leaves her in
response, and she's left with nothing and
nowhere to go at the end of
season 5.
It's just a tremendous character Arc from
start to finish a Belter's
Belter through and through.
a dockworker
rising through the ranks as a verifiable badass,
a competent Commander
with a moral compass.
And one that understands the game enough to
wonder if she wants to
play it at all.
An existence that's built on trying to decide
between
the lesser of two evils.
I think that scenario in the books where the
corporate boss wants to
cut pay by 3% because that will improve their
bottom line and it's not
a lot of money, right?
And the belters are just barely getting by
as it is.
So they say, what do you want us to do?
Eat three percent less food?
Breathe 3% less air? and then the reality
is, what are
they supposed to do about it?
We also get to see real humanity, intimacy,
and depth in her
connection with her family
only to see that tested by the reality around
them.
She was there to make sure the belt would
be involved when the ring
Gates opened.
And when she saw what that looked like she
walked away from it.
She had a chance to take out Marco personally,
but thought at the time
that it would lead to more violence.
If she did, she worked closely with
Anderson Dawes and Fred Johnson both of whom
rose to powerful positions
but in the end she felt they lost their way
once they got there.
I've watched and re-watched
This series more than any person should and
I'd be hard-pressed to
come up with a more interesting individual
story.
Drummer is the belt.
She's the belt.
And while there are other great belter characters
like Miller and
Naomi, they're somewhat disconnected from
where they came from and
that isn't a case with Camina and I think
that's a great place to leave things.
I didn't really get into it because the show
character took on a life of her own.
Because the creators like Cara Gee's performance
so much.
She just kept getting more stuff.
She just sort of kept absorbing different
aspects of characters.
They had to cut as she was becoming her own
thing.
One detail
that's pretty funny as that Bull is one of
the characters she replaced in season 3.
And when he was introduced in the show in
season 5, he basically took
over the role of the original Drummer when
she was first
introduced in the fifth book, they switched
places.
Mostly She's a combination of Sam, Bull and
Michio Pa, but the show's version
of Ashford got some of their stories as well.
beyond working for Fred Johnson,
She doesn't really have any of the book drummer.
Let me know what you think about this character,
what you like about her.
Why her story so great and if she's not the
best belter character
Who is? please like this video If you enjoyed
it, please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching.
I'll Talk to you soon.